so the first thing we need to do is
actually fetch the graphics context from
the tile that's been passed in now this
is gonna be the graphics context that
we're actually going to draw our bitmaps
to the first thing we do here is
actually call a fill rect just to clear
the background of this tile in case we
reuse this thing in the future for any
reason the next thing we're gonna do is
actually create a rectangle that has top
bottom left and right parameters that
represent the tile itself
we'll use this here in a second to pass
to the is visible function the next
thing we do is actually create a V rect
object with a top left bottom and right
value that represents the boundaries of
the tile and world space we then walk
through each tile for our map and much
like before determine whether or not
it's visible only this time we determine
whether or not it's visible to the Past
in canvas rather than the entire view
rect to do this we utilize the same
intersect rect function passing in the V
rec that we created before and creating
a new rectangle that represents the tile
that we're looking at if the tile is not
visible we then of course continue on if
it is visible we continue with our same
process modify world X and world Y
offsetting it by our new view rectangle
values and then we call our draw image
function now notice that the draw image
actually hasn't changed in fact most of
this code is actually identical to your
original draw function except that we're
now testing tiles against V rect given
from our canvas tile as well as drawing
to the V rect context